as computer technology continues to
evolve organizations are looking for
ways to build intelligent systems that
are ready to replace manual human
services
companies globally are working
rigorously to improve customer
experience and engagement using the
natural language processing technology
one of the most popular applications of
nlp is the chatbot so if you want to
learn the fundamentals of natural
language processing and its powerful
methods then we are here to help you
with that simply learns skillup platform
offers natural language processing and
text mining course for free you can kick
start your career in machine learning
and ai by learning the essentials of nlp
from this introductory course for free
you will gain the important skills and
get a course completion certificate as
well simply learns natural language
processing and text mining tutorial for
beginners skill of course is developed
by industry professionals and
experienced trainers for beginners
developers software engineers and
aspiring data scientists this course
will help you learn how to work with
natural language processing toolkit
library and make you understand text
mining extraction and processing methods
you will also look at a hands-on
demonstration on structuring sentences
the total duration of this free
introductory nlp course is 1 hour and
all the modules are self-paced video
lessons with 90 days of access to the
course this allows you to learn at your
own pace and convenience after
completing the course you will receive a
course completion certificate by simply
loan this certificate can be highlighted
in your resume to grab the attention of
potential recruiters isn't that amazing
so head over to our course page and
enhance your career in machine learning
and ai by enrolling in our free natural
language processing and text mining
tutorial for beginners course today sign
up now and get certified with simply
loan the link is in the description
below
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here